In the example we just discussed,
our hypothetical scope request contained a wildcard, the asterisk.
Through it, a client app is seeking permission to obtain
all available and future fire resources stored on the server for the current patient.
This raises the issue of patient privacy.
The authorization server asking a patient to authorize
a smart app requesting patient/*read,
should inform them that they are being asked to allow
the app access to all currently available and future
fire resources that might contain
potentially more sensitive data such as their genomic variations as we'll discuss later.
Of course, as we discussed when we looked at health vault,
giving the patient usable tools to select what they are willing to share is a challenge.
However, the granular nature of
fire resources could certainly facilitate the development of such a tool.
This would be particularly true if, as illustrated here,
in a medication request resource example from the fire site,
all applicable resources included the reason for orders and procedures.
If they did, then a patient might specify that they wish to share all information
related to a particular clinical problem
and the app could figure out what that information is.
At present, these cause and
effect relationships are not in all the applicable fire resources.
Even if they were,
this is not just an issue for the standard.
A complete solution would require vendor support of the idea in
the AMR and provide a willingness to take the time to indicate these relationships.
Alternately, this may well be another opportunity for machine learning
to infer relationships from the data recorded over many patient encounters.
The authorization server may not grant the level of access requested by the app.
For example, an app with the goal of obtaining read and write access to
our old friend the patients allergy intolerance resources,
request the clinical scope of
patient/AllergyIntolerance.* The authorization server
may respond in a variety of ways as shown here.
App designers should anticipate this.
And their apps should consider the permissions granted to
them and they may need to change their behavior accordingly.